[Musique]
Simone Veil
seul l'espoir apaise la douleur
[Musique]
un podcast original produit par Lina
écrit par les avenstein avec le concours
de Dominique Missika
[Musique]
juillet 1944
cela fait trois mois que Simone Veil sa
sœur et sa mère survivent à Auschwitz
une capo impressionnée par la beauté de
Simone lui propose de la transférer dans
un camp annexe réputé pour être un peu
moins dur tu es trop belle pour mourir
lui dit-elle Simone Veil accepte à
condition d'y emmener sa sœur et sa mère
elles arrivent toutes trois dans ce camp
de beau break le 8 juillet 1944
[Musique]
Simone Veil seul l'espoir apaise la
douleur
troisième épisode
de beaux breaks à bergenbelsen juillet
1944 avril 1945
et on est resté puisqu'on est suis
janvier si moi c'est beaucoup aussi moi
on vit dans les conditions qui sont tout
de même où il y a pas d'appel ou le
travail est terrassement enfin c'était
beaucoup moins dur la nourriture et pas
bien meilleure on a moins faim c'est pas
la nourriture qui était dure
alors les premiers mois bon bref j'ai
fait du terrassement enfin on était
moins surveillés c'était un petit camp
on était en tout
35 femmes je crois et puis 250 hommes
quelque chose comme ça mais les 35
femmes on était dans l'usine où on
travaillait et il y avait un étage qui
faisait un peu genre grenier on avait
c'est un grand espace on était tout
ensemble aucun appel là le SS venait le
soir nous comptait son amusement c'était
d'arriver au moment où vous êtes
toilette ou autre alors là ça fait des
bons chacun c'est vrai et puis
tu es arrivé avec nous une femme
française qui était dentiste de femmes
qui étaient venus du blog d'expérience
qui était française aussi d'origine
polonaise qui était communiste qui avait
été au bloc de l'expérience et qu'il est
sorti du bloc d'expérience et qui avait
été envoyé là par la filière communiste
parce que elle savait d'expérience enfin
le médecin leur avait dit vous savez
jusqu'à maintenant les
expériences n'avaient aucune importance
vous pouvez avoir aucune conséquence sur
votre santé mais maintenant je sais
vraiment je ne sais pas je peux pas vous
garantir quoi que ce soit donc
vraiment si plus il faut vous trouviez
un endroit pour partir et elle avait
plus se faire par la filière de soutien
venir je dois dire je dis ça sur elle
qui était les deux qui étaient
communistes et qui ont été même des amis
merveilleuses
il y avait pas d'abord de capot pour
surveiller ce travail et puis le SS il
était là il était pas là enfin c'était
pas
je dirais qu'il y avait un problème tout
de même à peu près que c'était
les hommes n'aiment pas beaucoup en
parler
je sais pas si ceux qui ont témoigné en
ont parlé ou pas
c'était tout de même je crois c'est le
seul camp que j'ai entendu parler comme
ça qui était un con les hommes et les
femmes étaient beaucoup ensemble
ça facilitait pas la vie quand on était
à berconnat Auschwitz qu'on avait la vie
quotidienne vraiment de déporter de base
homme aux femmes ça n'existait pas mais
tout de même on était très
on les rencontrer beaucoup les hommes et
puis il y en avait parmi eux qui étaient
très libres qui allait où il voulait qui
essayait vraiment de vous acheter par
tous les moyens
et alors ça faisait une pression qui
était insupportable par moment
insupportable parce qu'on était très peu
de femmes
donc quand on était aux terrassement que
j'étais avec maman il sera mais dès
qu'on était un tout petit peu isolé dans
comme ça on se trouvait seul et non et
puis qui faisait pas ça ils auraient pas
tenté c'était la pression morale
par exemple il y avait un
n'importe qui avait beaucoup de facilité
ou autre alors il voulait me donner à
manger mais il voulait exiger que il
travaillait dans la cuisine
pour la cuisine c'est juste en face
qu'une SS était en face de notre bloc et
moi je mangeais suffisamment ce qu'on
avait au camp bon j'avais pas j'étais
pas ça j'avais pas faim j'étais pas
femme et du tout j'ai pas à ce moment là
et un moment ne pouvait rien manger
alors je lui disais je veux la porter un
moment donné je dis non je la porte à
maman voilà chaque fois c'était pénible
c'était ce genre de choses mais c'était
quelquefois encore plus
et puis en même temps il y avait
d'autres qui étaient me souviens comme
ça qui m'a jamais rien demandé j'ai
jamais eu le moindre geste ni rien on a
passé Noël encore
alors je ne sais pas il était il était
dans les premiers numéros
étaient arrivés depuis très longtemps je
crois que c'était un Autrichien j'ai
jamais su grand chose sur lui et alors
je ne sais pas comment pour Noël
il s'était procuré du parfum pour moi
mais jamais rien demandé jamais rien il
m'avait donné un pyjama neuf il avait de
l'argent sûrement comment est-ce que
c'était procuré cet argent qu'est-ce qui
s'est pas et m'avait donné je me
souviens du parfum et
à pyjama alors ça c'était au camp
c'était
puis après alors je dois dire quand on
était avec concerto aussi avec tous les
beaucoup d'hommes alors là c'était un
autre chantage c'était les hommes qui
vous disent on n'a pas vu de femme
depuis 10 ans aussi c'était uniquement
bien sûr c'est toujours la même chose
c'était les capots les chefs de bloc les
gens qui avaient des responsabilités
pour ne rester que deux jours
[Musique]
et de beaux bras que vous sentez que
c'est la fin de bombardement
à partir de l'été d'abord on avait eu un
premier espoir à Bob break qui était
parce qu'on a su tout de suite comme il
y avait des gens du déportés qui
travaillaient dans les bureaux et tout
ça a été un espace très petit et que
vivait beaucoup plus
dialoguer entre nous se rencontrer plus
facilement donc on a su des qu'il y a eu
l'attentat contre Hitler on l'a su
immédiatement et on avait eu beaucoup
d'espoir qu'il a été tué dans l'attentat
malheureusement ça n'était pas le cas ça
a été une fausse pose joie mais à partir
je dirais du
mi-août mi-août septembre début
septembre on a vu qui a commencé à y
avoir un grand reflux de l'armée
allemande ça a commencé déjà très tôt
l'offensive russe et on a vu passer des
choses parce que le camp était juste au
bord de la route
entre
Cracovie et katovic vous voyez passer
des convois il me semble même moi j'ai
souvenir c'est pas de même de quelques
chameaux dans Madère avec des Mongols en
face on avait vu passer de tout et puis
des gens et puis après plus en plus plus
l'hiver à approcher et puis il y a eu
des populations des gens qui ont
commencé à faire envoyer très bien puis
on a entendu ensuite le camion et la
lueur du fond enfin donc ça c'est
beaucoup plus tôt
à l'automne mais le
à partir de début janvier on a vu que
c'était vraiment
et à ce moment-là un espoir qui était
celui qu'on pensait que la guerre
finirait très vite et on n'avait pas du
tout on savait pas du tout que dans les
arbres quand il y aurait l'échec des
Ardennes enfin tout ça serait très long
vous voyez ça pour terminer dans dans
les semaines à venir tellement cette on
avait le sentiment d'une pression
tellement tellement forte et surtout un
exode très très important et d'une
déroute allemande et puis en même temps
la crainte de se dire qu'est-ce qu'ils
font est-ce qu'ils auront le temps de
nous gazer avant de nous supprimer pour
qu'il reste rien à quel moment vous avez
compris que c'était réel le gazage très
vite de
je vais vous dire les gens quand
les gens ont eu la famille ils ont voulu
croire une journée ou deux mais quand
ils ont dès qu'on a rencontré des
françaises qui étaient là depuis un
moment qui nous ont dit la même chose et
ça ça a été tout de suite pendant la
quarantaine quand il y avait des
nouvelles qui arrivaient d'abord les
gens qui étaient là avaient toujours
peur de voir arriver de la famille donc
dès qu'il y avait un convoi de française
il venait pour venir aux nouvelles et
vérifier qu'il y avait personne se
renseignées
c'est aussi de savoir ce qui se passait
en France et déclave ce contact très
vite très vite on avait plus je dois
dire
dans la journée
pratiquement
on savait à quoi sentir et surtout alors
à partir du moment où on nous a dit que
on allait à Auschwitz on se dit au fixe
pourquoi enfin donc
on se demandait ce qui fait que en fait
notre groupe on a été jusqu'à monovis
puis on est revenu sur nos pas parce que
c'était pas dans la trajectoire et que
c'est au moment où quand on avait
dépassé aux Juifs et que le corps était
passé conseillé bon en tout cas voilà on
sait pas ce qu'ils vont faire de nous
mais en tout cas c'est pas on sera pas
gazé là vous pouvez nous fusils mais
c'était plus compliqué et on a marché
[Musique]
ça c'était le soir tard on était parti
j'ai pas encore complètement nuit vers
5h de bobrets qu'on avait été vers mon
avis sur le fils et puis on était vers
la vis qui devait être
70 et 80 km à peu près avant tout on a
dû faire 80 km on s'arrêtant juste
quelques heures dans une grange ou
presque tout le monde à un moment
quelconque de la marche s'est arrêté
d'ailleurs on est arrivé avec la vie où
il y avait alors d'abord il y avait des
camps et puis j'avais ramené les gens de
toute cette région parce que toute la
zone d'Auschwitz est une zone où il y
avait énormément de Candes commandes
plusieurs dizaines de milliers donc on
s'est retrouvé très nombreux là et
où il y avait là aussi on distribuerait
rien et où là les femmes ont été
privilégiées un peu parce que comme on a
travaillé dans la cuisine des SS on nous
a donné du pain de la soupe enfin les
cheveux et à boire les gens avaient
vraiment rien à boire ni à manger et
puis on est resté deux jours comme ça
pas très longtemps et vis je crois qu'il
y a eu des sélections mais des
sélections où on passait comme ça sans
savoir même que c'était la sélection on
passait devant les SS et puis
bon tous ces gens ont assez
qui venaient vraiment il y en avait fini
qui était
des portées depuis
39-40 en fin depuis des années ou même
détenu avant déjà probablement il peut y
avoir
parmi les politiques
d'anciens communistes d'anciens
sorcellaires enfin des premières le
premier allemand des années
33 34 il en restait pas beaucoup ils ont
resté pas beaucoup mais à partir quand
ils avaient franchi un certain temps et
surtout les Allemands ils en avaient
besoin dans les bureaux il leur servait
on a beaucoup dit que beaucoup d'entre
eux
avaient disparu à la fin
parce que ça va être autre chose pour
témoigner mais c'était
c'était assez d'enfer de Nantes
c'était
[Musique]
des gens qui pensent qu'ils vont mourir
donc
il recherche n'importe quel jouissance
n'importe quoi
y compris les SS d'ailleurs parce qu'au
fond les
nécessairement aussi menacé puisque les
Russes étaient tout près
pour moi ça reste toujours aussi
incompréhensible mais d'ailleurs
certains historiens
de ça c'est que je crois que c'est
Philippe burin où je peux qu'elle
historien comme ça qui dit que
l'obsession
de tuer les Juifs étaient pour Hitler à
un moment plus important que la victoire
et moi c'est ce que j'ai ressenti
pourquoi est-ce qu'on nous est avec eux
il a fallu nous mettre en des trains on
était incapable de travailler on était
plus bon à rien de toute façon c'était
la moitié sont morts dans les trains
dans chacun c'est qu'on voit qui était
souvent de 15 ans de mille des wagons à
bois sous la neige sans manger sans
faire plus de la moitié sont morts
qu'est-ce qu'il est resté tous ces gens
quand on nous a fait ensuite quelquefois
partir d'un camp pour les derniers jours
tout ça
parce qu'il est sur les cadavres et
vraiment alors moi si j'ai eu ce
sentiment de la vie surtout parce que je
suis convaincu à gregis sinon pas pu
évacuer tous les d'abord les Allemands
les similialement il y en avait beaucoup
ni les soldats ni les SS certainement
beaucoup sont restés et on a fait partir
des trains avec des mouvements c'est
très bien ça chacun de ces trains
c'est au moins la moitié qui est mort
[Musique]
on est donc évacué avec son français
train qui était des
trains complètement ouvert des plateaux
à bois
d'autres dans des wagons peut-être un
peu plus haut pour le charbon mais là
c'est des plateaux à bois on était
entassés et tellement fantastique que
comme on se battait pour se faire un peu
de place vous pouvez même pas ce soir
il y en avait qui essayait de vous jeter
par-dessus la rambarde
pour se faire de la place simplement
pour rester ma sœur avait des traces de
griffes
qu'il avait eu certaines déportés qu'il
avait griffé dans le wagon pour essayer
la sortir dehors et il y avait que des
femmes ou c'était mélangé donc on était
pas mélangé
femme alors ce qui est extraordinaire on
est passé de la vie c'est le
sud-est alors après on est passé très
rapidement
on ne passait par le Tchécoslovaquie les
faubourg de Prague dans les faubourgs de
Praz comme on était dans ses wagons tout
à fait ouvert on passait pas très loin
des maisons les Tchèques avaient dû
avoir déjà plusieurs trains qui étaient
passés ils nous ont envoyé du pain ils
ont envoyé ce qu'il pouvait alors on
recevait ce qui patoum enfin tout de
même pas mal puis quand on s'est arrêté
dans une gare il venait apporter des
sauts de dos enfin et du jour même au
moment où passer la frontière c'est fini
non non mais on a vu le moment
et puis ensuite
passer par l'Autriche on était à
Mathausen maintenant
on est resté quelques heures on est
reparti vers le nord dans ce qu'on voit
et ce train a été jusqu'à Dora
et adorable
la moitié des gens était mort on arrive
en Paris mais les femmes personnes je
crois pas une seule femme on était très
peu nombreuses comme femme il y avait
notre groupe de bobren et puis il y
avait un groupe de femmes tziganes
on est a été dans une petite baraque qui
était à l'entrée du camp et d'ailleurs
il y a un livre sur Dora et pas que les
archives du dosage a reçu une fois une
lettre comme ça de gens qui m'ont écrit
en disant on a vu que vous aviez été
adorable dans le seul qu'on voit où il y
a eu des femmes qui se sont arrêtées à
dehors et on était je sais pas peut-être
un tout une soixantaine donc comme ça
peut-être un petit peu plus et on est
resté donc c'était à l'extérieur du camp
tous les hommes sont entrés parce que
beaucoup sont morts encore ensuite les
femmes ont toutes survécu il y a une
femme qui a couché dans la nuit une
femme tzigane qui a couché dans la nuit
on l'a tué tout de suite le bébé a été
tout de suite elle a tué je crois même
si ses amis mais à la survécu à coucher
comme ça
des Français qui ont appris que de
quitter adoration après qu'il y avait
des Françaises et qui sont venus nous
apporter
à manger et on t'a appris qu'il y avait
des Françaises là-dessus le SS les a
surpris et
recevoir une de gifle
et puis nous au bout de deux ou trois
jours on est reparti pour Bergen Melz on
n'est pas restés adora enfin c'était
inscrit dans les archives de Laura
parmi les hommes aucun des hommes qui
étaient avec nous à Bob Marley était
dans ce train donc je n'ai rien su de ce
qui était adorent les hommes qui étaient
avec nous beaucoup sont partis à Berlin
parce qu'il faut à cause des
bombardements il fallait déblayer la
ville les pierres etc et puis donc nous
sommes restés juste deux jours et on est
reparti alors cette fois en wagon fermé
wagon à besti ordinaire mais on n'était
pas du tout entassés parce qu'on était
peu nombreuses et jusqu'à Bergen
le 30 ou le 31 janvier quelque chose
comme ça on avait quitté le 18 janvier
et à bergenbergen
il y avait encore pas trop de monde
c'est après qu'il y a eu c'est à partir
de ce moment-là qu'il y a eu les grandes
une grande évacuation sur Bergen Melsen
alors nous ça va réveiller il y avait
des françaises qui étaient arrivés
venant de d'Auschwitz beaucoup plus tôt
vers le j'avais eu des notamment des
hongroises mais pas seulement même parmi
les Français certaines qui étaient
partis au mois d'octobre qui avait
quitté
Bernard ma belle-sœur par exemple et qui
est parti à ce moment-là qui est passée
à bergenberzenne et enfin moi je la
connaissais pas encore un certain nombre
quitté à ce moment-là mais il y a eu
surtout énormément d'arriver absolument
de toutes les régions puisque
l'Allemagne c'est petit à petit réduite
de plus en plus c'est la Pologne tous
les gens sont bifurqués vers cette
région qui était une région qui
paraissait à ses éloignés de tout
les gens ils sont morts
de faim
de soif et surtout
une toute petite chambre à gaz dans
certains cas tout à fait mais enfin je
crois pas
mais les gens la mortalité
les dernières semaines a été croyant le
plus c'est le typhus mais c'est aussi
c'est aussi la fin
parce que je crois qu'il y a eu de enfin
on l'a dit mais je
beaucoup de raisons de croire que c'est
vrai qu'il y a eu du cannibalisme
[Musique]
on travaillait pas enfin moi j'ai
travaillé j'ai considéré que c'était une
grande grande chance de travailler sinon
j'ai rencontré c'est comme ça par hasard
que j'ai rencontré Sonia nouveau elle a
été chef du camp comme dans les mêmes
fonctions puisqu'elle avait
à toujours très c'est une belle femme
très allure et rencontrer par hasard
parce que mon travail un peu dans et
elle m'a reconnu tout de suite et elle
m'a mise dans un des rares activités qui
avait Bergat de valsen puisqu'on ne
pouvait pas occuper les gens elle m'a
mise à la cuisine de SS ce qui
évidemment était un très grand privilège
mais moi j'ai d'abord je sais pas voler
je sais pas m'organiser c'est seulement
après la je dirais après la Libération
qu'on m'a expliqué comment il fallait
faire pour les vols parce que le vol en
plus on le faisait sur la queue sur les
SS alors on avait pas beaucoup de
scrupules mais en fait comme il y avait
celles qui travaillent à la cuisine des
SS et puis celles qui travaillaient pour
la cuisine ordinaire on communique
facilement avec elle m'a expliqué alors
il fallait leur apporter de la soupe la
soupe qu'on mangeait pas nous parce que
on avait autre chose on leur apportait
de la soupe et en échange elle nous
sortait les trucs parce que elle n'était
pas fouillée tandis que nous on était
fouillé beaucoup plus surveillé
vraiment tout à fait tout à fait
incapable j'ai appris ça la Libération
les prix aussi d'ailleurs parce que
Valais les choses parce qu'il y avait
les gens qui volaient pour se nourrir ou
pour des amis il y avait aussi ce qui
vendait
c'est toujours fait aussi
mais moi je me faisais prendre je me
faisais prendre quand je voulais du
sucre de SS c'est à dire que le lait
qu'on faisait cure pour les SS il y
avait un peu moins de la personne n'y
voyait rien mais alors je faisais un
travail qui avait l'air frère posant et
très
sans inconvénient mais qui a été
terrible d'abord parce que j'ai failli
me faire envoyer mais c'était comme il
n'y avait plus rien à eux-mêmes n'avait
plus de farine avec plein j'avais des
pommes de terre alors on était on avait
des des tonneaux et on devait râper il y
avait des grosses frappes on rappelle
les pommes de terre et j'avais
l'impression que je m'étais plus de son
dans la pomme de terre râpée il y avait
que toute ma peau par tel que tout ça
pour un [ __ ] parce que j'arrivais pas à
aller assez vite on disait toujours on
devait faire un tonneau dans la journée
alors je rajoute en douce je rajoute de
l'eau parce que ça se comme ça rend
beaucoup d'eau les toutes mais
j'arrivais tout de même pas à faire mon
plein de comment dormait presque pas la
nuit parce qu'il y avait des la nuit il
y avait des allers très souvent
partaient très tard on traiterait tard
dans le camp et j'ai dû en plus avoir
diffuses sur mes mains en compte moi
j'ai la plupart des maladies que j'ai je
crois toutes les maladies que j'ai eu
dans ma vie ça a toujours été des
maladies qui ne comme la scarlatine je
crois que j'ai tout
j'ai jamais malade j'avais la grippe
j'ai jamais rien alors que j'ai des
choses quand même mais on les on s'en
aperçoit pas et là j'ai dû j'ai dû avoir
le typhus parce que d'après des tests le
médecin en rentrant mais vous avez
sûrement un petit fusse maman est mort
du typhus ma sœur a eu très gravement
mais enfin
très content une fois parce que je me
suis fait prendre tout de même avec du
sucre que j'avais évolu pour elle et
j'ai trouvé qu'ils étaient alors j'ai dû
faire je sais pas combien de temps
ramper par terre et m'ont laissé le
sucre
alors je sais pas s'ils ont oublié de le
prendre ou sinon on est ici par en
disant que j'avais payé suffisamment
mais
tout ça n'a pas été une période très
longue mais une période
terrible
terrible parce que vraiment des cadavres
on a vu tous ces films de témoignages
les cadavres étaient assimilés c'était
des squelettes les câlins
j'ai pesais je sais pas les gens avaient
des dysenteries épouvantables j'avais
pas le temps de sortir
vraiment épouvantable il y avait plus un
endroit
pour se loger dans les mêmes dans les
toilettes dans les lavabos les gens
étaient sous les
quand les anglais sont arrivés on savait
qu'ils allaient arriver d'ailleurs
mettaient confirmés récemment j'ai eu un
livre d'un anglais expliquant que
l'accord entre les Anglais les
Allemands c'est des fêtes quelques jours
avant et d'ailleurs on avait vu on
voyait SS avec des brassards blancs mais
d'ailleurs les SS
convaincus beaucoup sont morts
du typhus aussi et
dans les anglais sont arrivés
épouvantail ne pouvait pas croire ce
qu'il voyait
alors il y avait le typhus se répond par
les poux alors il y avait tellement de
poux dans les vêtements que l'on
n'arrivait plus à s'en débarrasser on
essayait n'importe quoi et je me
souviens une fois comme ça je marchais
si après je marchais et puis de loin
jouer un chandin et je dis oh tiens il
est en angora là ce que j'ai moche je
vais changer c'était l'élanzes qui
donnait le sentiment qu'il y avait de
l'angora sur le pourtour du champ
d'arrêt c'est fou c'est fou il y en
avait c'était effrayant et ce que j'ai
le plus apprécié en arrivant à Lutetia
mais déjà on en avait vu un peu ce que
c'était
c'était on était dévoré
on pouvait rien faire on peut plus rien
faire
d'ailleurs il y a aucun moyen de se
laver il y avait plus d'eau le seul eau
qui avait c'était il y avait deux ou
trois empêchements qui étaient qui
avaient été de petits des bassins et qui
était devenu une espèce de marécage on
l'a acheté n'importe quoi et on les
avait les gens avaient tellement soif il
y avait tellement pas d'eau dans le
temps que j'étais entouré de barbelés et
les gens passaient les barbelés se
faisaient tuer pour aller chercher de
l'eau dans ses bassins dégoûtants mon
jeter n'importe quoi
en plus quand les gens sont malades ils
ont régulièrement soif
alors ça évidemment
le fait même d'être dans la cuisine et
je sais je pouvais rien manger j'étais
incarne de manger mais dans la cuisine
SS on faisait cuire du lait et l'enjeu
je volais moi qui aime pas le lait qui
de nouveau n'aime pas ce moment-là je
volais deux trois verbes ça c'était très
facile il y a aucun risque les grandes
culs de l'être juste à côté de l'endroit
où il y avait mes raps à pommes de terre
alors je me levais j'allais boire un
verre de linge prenais avec mon mais
c'est pas un endroit qui était qui avait
été destiné à ça et c'est le
l'accumulation
d'ailleurs les Anglais ont été eux-même
tellement dépassés et horrifiés que le
général
anglais a donné sa émission enfin
demandé à repartir au front très peu de
temps après parce que la guerre était
pas finie parce qu'il dit j'ai aucun
moyen je peux rien faire et ne
supportait pas le
et vous parlez de l'hôtel Lutetia vous
posiez combien à ce moment-là vous savez
combien vous peser à votre retour
j'avais déjà beaucoup grossi
devait peser leur mon la libération
[Musique]
30-35 kg et là 40
Simone Veil
seul l'espoir apaise la douleur
un podcast original en quatre épisodes
produits par Lina
réalisée par mexomnoises
écrits avec le concours de Dominique
Missika
avec la voix des adorada musique
originale Michael yo
[Musique]
ce podcast a été réalisé à partir du
témoignage de Simone Veil recueilli par
Catherine Bernstein le 9 mai 2006 dans
le cadre de mémoire de la Shoah une
initiative de la Fondation pour la
mémoire de la Shoah et de Lina
[Musique]
l'intégralité du récit de Simone Veil
est disponible en librairie dans seul
l'espoir apaise la douleur une coédition
Flammarion INA et en vidéo sur le site
des grands entretiens de Lina entretien
au pluriel point fr